ok let's get into audience questions for
the week first one is from Henny Henny
says David you've talked about the
concept stochastic terrorism before
could stochastic terrorism ever be
prosecuted as a crime if you could prove
why an individual committed a certain
crime if it was based on what they saw
on TV said by a particular journalist or
pundit okay I think the answer is
probably not know so for people who
don't know if stochastic terrorism is
the idea that if you have a big platform
and you go out on that platform and you
say day after day after day so-and-so is
a terrible person and something needs to
be done about them they are kidnapping
children and killing people you whatever
right and you say this person is a
problem this person is a problem given a
sufficiently large enough audience of
people you would start to realize that
the probability that at least one person
in that audience by virtue of having
heard you say this is a bad person we
need to do something about is actually
going to go out there and might attack
the person you've been demonizing or
might kill the person you've been
demonizing there's a notable situation
related to Glenn Beck and an
organization called the tides foundation
for maybe I don't know if it's like 6 8
or maybe even more like 10 years ago at
this point so the question is given that
people are motivated to do things
sometimes by external factors could we
ever say if someone says yeah I killed
them because Sean Hannity said so or
whatever could Sean Hannity be held
liable and the answer is basically no
okay if you have someone specifically
and openly inciting physical violence on
a program or in the streets or whatever
that is potentially criminal regardless
of whether anybody actually acts on it
okay and that would have to be evaluated
individually by law enforcement and by
our justice system to determine whether
doing that is a crime standing on the
street as people walk by and going this
person is a child molester kill this
person attack this person do it do it do
it that in and of itself regardless of
where and whether anybody acts because
of what you're doing
can be criminal but they're based on how
our current understanding of what crime
is and the degree of agency that exists
unless someone wants to plead insanity
on the basis of their actions which also
wouldn't link back to the stochastic
terrorist I don't know how you hold a
stochastic terrorist accountable for a
crime committed because of their
propaganda and their public
pronouncements and I also I'm answering
the question as asked which is would
this be possible I'm not even addressing
whether this would be a good thing
because it could have significant
unintended consequences I mean I can
understand how it face value it might
sound good to say hey you know what if
Trump's rhetoric is leading to Muslims
or Jews or whoever being targeted and
beaten up it would be great to hold
Trump accountable for that well yes it
would and the accountability should be
that he's immediately voted out of
office at the first opportunity but I
think there are probably other
unintended consequences if he could be
held legally liable individually for
those that general climate that he
foments that may go along with
consequences we don't like as much in
terms of free speech and and in other
ways but to answer the question
I don't know that stochastic terrorists
under our current sort of organization
and how the law works I don't know how
you're ever going to prosecute them as
criminals beyond simply the legal
infrastructure we already have around
incitement of violence and a calls for
public calls for attacks and bullying
and the like